[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello and welcome back to the break room
this is our daily live show that keeps
you updated on all the nerdy fandom news
you need to know no coming up today we
got a fast 10 trailer just up the road
just around the bend we're speeding
towards it we're not gonna slow down
quarter mile you say quarter mile at a
time Pocahontas I would say thinking
something Matt Reeves is deep in Batman
black panther 3 news and much much more
today on the break room uh I'm of course
braided bear who cares across the table
for me we got Tommy Bechtel hey
everybody look at all this torso
yeah see you soon Hagrid's motorcycle
ride this ain't fairity it's Coles it
comes in big boy sizes and next to me uh
another day older another day wiser as
Jessica Clemens this is from American
Eagle I thought we were just saying
we're our brand of clothing oh okay well
this is from new rockstarsmerch.com WoW
check it out support the channel grab
yourself your own new rockstars merch
let those people in the wild know that
you support new rock stars they'll give
you a high five they'll say hey how
about that breakdown Tommy did of Modoc
wasn't it great and you'll say yes it
was great and you'll go about your lives
if you never speak to that person ever
again can I ask a question yeah does new
Rockstar's merch have hats oh they got
hats they got stickers I think I got
enamel pins they had all sorts of stuff
check it out new rockstarsmerch.com but
before we can look at any more merch we
have got to talk about these
headlines your headlines something must
be done about your headlines something
must be done about this headlines folks
collider is reporting that a trailer for
the upcoming fast 10 or fast X I don't
know where you follow on that debate the
trailer is coming it's going to debut on
February 10th mark your calendars the
trailer will Air two days before the
Super Bowl is it gonna over this was
that an accident they were like we
bought a Super Bowl man it's gonna be
February 10th the Super Bowl is February
12th
son of them well three minutes long
during the Super Bowl you know expensive
that would be that's the thing yeah
they're reporting of this trailer is
over three minutes long it's got to be
coming before movies right that's a
Friday Friday the 10th so it's gonna be
in theaters I don't know if it'll be on
TV I bet though well I bet they'll put
it on I I bet it will Air during the
Super Bowl at some point if they want to
get out fresh because now it's like you
because uh Super Bowl is all about
commercials we love the commercials now
you got to get your commercial off
before the Super Bowl to get the early
news yeah get the early headlines
because you don't want to compete with
the big dogs at the Super Bowl I'm not
in any Super Bowl commercials this year
but a company is paying me to write all
over my body and I will be streaking oh
okay you're gonna streak the Super Bowl
yeah where's it at this year uh it's in
Glendale Arizona oh okay great
congratulations it'll be nice and warm
yeah and Glendale prisons have really
comfortable benches next time that's
good next headline David F Sandberg
teased the trailer for Shazam 2 by the
end of this month on his Twitter earlier
this week there's the little we all know
that green band we know what it means oh
good they didn't they don't show uh
we're not getting ready
going to town I'm Helen Mirren
I'm sorry Dane Helen Mirren there you go
there you go I mean if that's love hears
that idea it'll make an extra million
bucks he might throw it in the movies
[Music]
Shazam too if you're the gods releases
on March 17th happy St Patrick's Day and
happy birthday to Patty uh is Maddie's
birthday St Patrick's Day I will never
confirm that uh patio furniture yes next
headline deadline is reporting that
James Gunn and Peter Safran will be
announcing some of their slate at the
end of this month
guns seemingly confirm this while
responding to a fans tweet he loves to
do it he does uh the fan was asking for
a DCU slate for their birthday on
January 14th and uh gun said quote for a
late birthday present sure at least he's
honest at least he's honest I'll show
you how late well maybe he's honest he
hasn't done it yet so we'll see do you
think James Gunn I don't want to get
gross here do you think James is in the
bathroom a lot because he responds to so
many tweets and I think I can think of
having that type of focus on responding
to tweets is that he's just taking that
weird colon thing they advertise on
Instagram that you know turns your body
into a conveyor belt you know what ads
do you get uh erectile dysfunction
Extreme Weight Loss uh gay cruises and
and colon blow okay
eviscerator great
great I think
being you should
you should leave a text message or a
comment on on your social media post or
a reply tweet I would the over should be
that it came from someone sitting on the
toilet yeah never the under yeah never
the under that's what I thought I mean
like James Gunn is so good about
responding to people our own Mt has a
great back and forth with him
or as I call it my crying closet I love
it cried on this show was so long but
the colon eviscerator
we're all cute we're all animals folks
yeah dumb I also I just imagine that his
wife is probably like honey dinner and
he's like I have to respond to some
tweets because you have to go to the
bathroom it's okay that's why he's like
I'm not pooping in here I'm responding
to tweets honey we've been married for a
year now it's okay I know that you go to
the bathroom we all do it no I'm
responding to tweets you got to keep up
the magic Batman Batman can fly in this
next movie see James you're pooping in
the living room all right sorry
speaking of Batman pooping in the living
room Matt Reeves has confirmed he is
currently writing a sequel to the Batman
we knew there was going to be another
movie uh he's writing the sequel he's
confirmed it Reeves has signed a
multi-year deal with Warner Brothers
last August and when asked if he was
shooting anything this year he said
quote we're deep in it and my partner
and I are writing Matson and I are
writing and it's really exciting and I'm
really excited about what we're doing uh
that was the quote there's no release
window yet for the film uh so we don't
know about that we also know he's
working on like a series that's like
Gotham PD series or whatever that's
going to turn out to be so is he a fast
wired I hope so a fast whiter fast
whiter I don't know I haven't asked him
lately uh next headline Misha green who
was tapped to write the Black Canary
movie for DC recently deleted all of her
tweets that's guarding the film on the
toilet just add on the toilet to all
these days possibly uh but I mean this
is sad because we're excited about a
Black Canary movie uh
do we know are we confirm that it is
kicked out I mean we are we speculated
everyone's speculating but what if like
they keep the idea I'm also holding on
to this worth as much as I can they keep
the idea and just got rid of the writer
there was no like announcement from
Warner Brothers that was like we're
never doing a Black Canary movie or
we're not doing that right now they
didn't even talk about this this is just
kind of some inference people are making
from her deleting these tweets
we talked about this uh when these you
know the acts was being swung around by
you could pretty much assume anything
that hasn't been shot or was like in
production being shot is probably off
the slate and as much as I like stuff
that was being written is probably being
reconsidered and they could still do a
Black Canary movie I think the
difference I think that that is I think
like you know this is it's easy to get
into a panic and and to be upset and
it's understandable to be upset about
all these cancelizations but obviously
they kind of have to go all in on
saffron and gun right and their vision
and they're gonna hire other creators
presumably they're not just straight
white guys to make movies about
characters that are not just straight
white guys and as much as right now it's
a holding pattern it's easy for me to
just say I get I I have to believe that
once the slates announced we'll be like
oh right of course they're doing a Black
Canary there may even be a Batgirl movie
maybe not a movie made but like a
Batgirl series or something like that so
it's just such an odd time because we're
in like an information vacuum and our
soul our main source is variety articles
that that move James Gunn to correct
them like variety articles that are have
information that's wrong so James
corrects them on Twitter we're not
getting any official releases from the
company so just say just guys that kid's
getting a birthday present or something
whatever James said he was doing a
birthday present in the bathroom that oh
boy I was gonna say kind of off that
note the situation of like
um if they are rewriting and getting rid
of everything it seems kind of like not
asinine but like ridiculous to be like
yeah we're gonna get rid of canary and
redo her but we're gonna keep Harley
Quinn the exact same yeah yeah um but he
did but he did already work with Margot
Roby as Harley Quinn James Gunn did so
and the suicide so I guess he he kind of
he's like this is Suicide Squad Harley
but we're gonna get rid of birds of prey
Harley right well but we have to see the
slash movie about how they describe
their version of the Multiverse and who
gets pulled in because they can pull
what they did in the comics where they
started the new 52 and they just kind of
reset they could do that and you could
use some old actors you could use news
new actors yeah we don't know we don't
know
next headline speaking of Harley Quinn
Hilder what
a wonderful composer named Hilder
guateer
who worked on Chernobyl and the first
Joker film will be returning as a
composer for Joker fuele
diagnir again apologies to Hilder uh she
won an Oscar for her score on 2019's
Joker so I'm just going back to the
second one and again this one's going to
be more of a musical so we'll see what
that means did she do some of the Star
Wars TV stuff too or is it I'm not 100
sure she might have I don't know is it
fun when I ask you a question yeah that
I'm not a proctor that I just need you
to just kind of know off the top of your
head I love that those are kind of I
don't believe she worked on Andor that
was it yeah some great bangers came out
of Andor these candid moments are what
connect us
watching right now
oh don't dislike these videos
Avatar
and Chernobyl with Kate Blanchett no
Star Wars she just wants that Academy
Award she's gunning she's got one
she wants another one next headline I
want an Academy Award
[Laughter]
the first reviews are coming in for the
last of us and folks it's a hit the show
currently has an 82 on Metacritic which
for comparison is the same score that
showrunner Craig Mason's Chernobyl has
uh reviews are praising the show not
only is a great video game adaptation
but has a genuinely good show the first
episode premieres on HBO Max this Sunday
Eric's gonna be breaking down the
episodes we might be doing a little
after show on Mondays for the last of us
I hope you're excited uh John has
watched the first episode and won't stop
talking about it and won't share it with
anybody uh so we're very excited for the
last of us we hope you guys are excited
too
um I can't wait it's good to hear that
it's getting good reviews I'm excited
you know I I admittedly I'm not a I
don't do a ton of gaming and I and I
definitely was not familiar with this
other than just that it was very popular
but now people that I trust are saying
the show is good they have already told
me the game is good I'm ready to become
one of The Last of Us you ready to be it
yeah I mean game is great when I would
argue some of the best parts of the game
or when you're just sitting there
watching the uh parts that happen in
between people oh yeah
yeah so the best part of Red Dead
Redemption is when you shave no it's
when you uh get drunk and then you go
take a bath
it's dagger to get a bath or try
collecting every horse which is the
hardest thing to do I think it's when
you hog tie a banker and throw them into
a pond with an alligator in it that is
fun too very fun no thank you uh next
headline the goal I'm not talking about
a game by the way the whole thing clubs
from last night Thomas Tommy do not kill
any more Bankers the Golden Globes were
last night did you guys remember that on
Tuesday y'all see that how fun y'all saw
that house of the Dragon took home best
television series drama and they
credited talking dragons for helping
them I know
wow I said Thank you talking dragons wow
for really uh promoting the show there's
a Jessica's shock at every episode was
so warranted and greatly needed um
Michelle yo and kuhe Kwan both took home
awards for best actor and actress and uh
sorry Michelle you're one for best
actress and K Quan won for best
supporting actor in a music or comedy
and Angela Bassett took home best
supporting actress in a film for her
role in wakanda Forever This is the
first major award for acting that a
Marvel movie has won so congratulations
what kind of forever is coming is coming
for those they're gonna make so many
moves for uh for the MCU and just award
season because it was not even about it
was just like the acting was so good the
writing was good and I'm just like oh
they're gonna come through what phase is
the whale in Marvel is that phase four
or face is it an origin story for whale
man or is it it's the preface for phase
five I think okay the whale starts is
getting you ready for phase five free
it's an amazing you see the way that
ends then you're not prepared for
Facebook on the red carpet last night at
the Golden Globes Leticia Wright gave us
some very exciting news when asked about
Black Panther three being greenlit she
said quote I think it's already in the
works it's gonna take a while we're
really excited for you guys to see that
of course they're making a black panther
three but I mean this movie wouldn't
come out until phase seven at least
there's no way it happens before the
interface before the end of Secret Wars
but we we gotta assume we're gonna see
Leticia right as Black Panther in either
Kang Dynasty or Secret Wars one of these
teammates yeah 100 I also think we're
gonna see
um wakanda be like the start of battle
world and it's gonna be during after
Secret Wars or even during Secret Wars
it's gonna be the first place that's
like exploded okay yeah but time is
getting rough so they're gonna bro watch
the third movie be like well we don't
have a place to live now
where are we gonna go next it could be
it could be um we've got a lot more to
talk about on the show today but first
we got to thank some of the awesome
people bringing the show to you uh and
one of those people is upside we all
want to save money in 2023 and upside is
an incredible app for anyone who wants
to for anyone who buys gas grocery or
dines out with upside you can get cash
back on purchases you make every day
it's basically cash back for just doing
you and we all do you every day we do
each of it that you do so well it's true
upside even offsets the inflated prices
by giving you cash back on purchases
it's also it's incredibly easy to use
the app to get started all you do is
download the free upside app use our
promo code break room and as an extra
special bonus you can get an extra 25
cents back on for every first for every
gallon of uh gas you get on your first
tank of gas using upside to use it you
just claim an offer for whatever you're
buying on upside you're going to get gas
you're going to go eat at a restaurant
you go buy some groceries look for the
deals on the app go to that place pay as
usual with a credit or debit card and
follow the steps in the app to get Aid
you can earn three times more cashback
with upside than with most Credit Card
Rewards or loyalty programs plus upside
doesn't sell your personal information
to third parties which is very nice
upside users are earning hundreds of
dollars a year that's why they have such
a great rating on the App Store download
the free upside app and use promo code
break room that's promo code break room
you know it to get an extra 25 cents
back for every gallon on your first tank
of gas thank you upside for sponsoring
the show today thank you upside thank
you
speaking of giving thanks and delicious
foods we want to thank our friends at
hellofresh for sponsoring this episode
of the break room as well eating well is
a top of mind I got sorry the prompt is
blocked by a light here I'm at the
analog
eating well is top of mind this month
and it's comforting to know you always
get top quality with hello fresh hello
fresh makes dinner time so so easy with
Fast and Furious and easy fresh recipes
hellofresh also has a line of delicious
filling meals
that are already in less than 15 minutes
enjoy taste and quality Done Quick with
recipes like Sesame beef tacos heard of
them Thai spiced pork meatballs or their
winner winner orzo chicken dinner meal
I'm uncomfortable with that much
boasting but I still think it's
delicious as I've said previously this
week I used to cook for a family of
three
and we were so happy after dinner we
paint and tell stories and drink hot
cocoa now I make my hellofresh meal and
slam a Michelob Ultra until I get dizzy
America's number one meal kit this
little mulch is basically a juice you
should try it for yourself go to
hellofresh.com break room 22 and use
code break room for 22 free meals plus
free shipping that's hellofresh.com
break room 22 and you got to use the
code break room 22 to help us help you
you're getting 22 free meals out of the
kindness of my heart on the break room I
am giving you 22 free meals only if you
use the code and hey maybe we have a
meal sometime maybe I make you some
winner winner chicken dinner or so huh
does that sound nice well that voice is
horrible
bing bong bing bong before we get into
our discussion today uh thank you for
our super chats out there there was an
interesting Super Chat from Bucky Barnes
ATL who point this out and I'm wondering
this about this movie as we get into
quantumania he was saying well Ant-Man
go up King's peach in this movie now we
all know the butt the button sorry uh
now we all know the infamous put Ant-Man
up thanos's rear end and uh have him
grow and boom Thanos is dead do you
think they're gonna at least make a
reference to that in this movie I watch
uh Cassie bring it up
and he's like no I can't do that I don't
want to do that it's not how it works I
think there will be at least a reference
to it thank God are you gonna bypass the
suit I mean the the boys delivered on
that albeit
uh sneak attack to a different entry I
wish it was a butt I I wouldn't give it
it wasn't anything but it was an
accident it was an accidental sneeze but
he definitely was in there on purpose he
was in there his shrinking down and
entering was on purpose we know we saw
it wait listen let's talk more about the
quantum realm Jessica you guys so in the
trailer we see in the quantum Mania
trailer the the there's this tentacles
that's around Scott I think we might
have an image of it do we John yeah
or two a portal and what if that portal
is an exit or entrance to a different
realm within the quantum it's getting
smaller to go into it right yeah right
you said we got Realms on Realms on
rounds as well that's the question so
the we also have a new quote from
Quantum media director Peyton Reed
saying creating the quantum well
Quantum creating the quantum World
Walters lives it keeps it's so hard to
say creating the quantum realm it's the
ultimate Act of world creation the idea
is that they go farther down into the
quantum realm than we've seen in the
previous further down
yeah farther down that's my pastor's
name
uh originally you guys so the Quan so if
you can go further into the quantum
realm I think this that uh question is
kind of setting up two examples that a
there could be more civilization down
there because it's parallel or we could
be going deeper inside and create
Quantum problems not the floor so we
have these here and I will draw it
really quick so normally
like you're just going straight through
right but I'm suspect oh I have it on my
microphone but I'm hoping that if this
is the Quantum realm we are literally
going through it through another quantum
realm through another quantum
you just drew a stripper imagine this is
a stripper on a circle stage she dives
into the pool okay now I get it as she
slides down the pole the pole elongates
and but she gets smaller and there's no
end oh she never reaches the bottom her
boobs are the dimension on her butt or
the
all right we'll get into it so either
way originally the quantum realm was the
micro
microverse from the comics but due to
licensing we started calling the quad we
started calling it The quantum adorable
uh the which is um this is a microverse
is that like exists somewhere else is
there another property they don't do
this yeah that's another I asked another
question that would that was not uh
pre-planned I'm really on fire today
guys there were a team of astronauts
called the micro knots and they were
attached to that but that is attached to
I think Paramount so they can't Marvel
can't use microverse so they know the
Top Gun can use the microverse they're
good the the fun thing about it too is
the Quantum realm they made a lot more
easier to understand than the microverse
but that gives it gives us little to
work with so the microverse was small
they considered it to live in space
between atoms it was believed at the
time that it could have universes within
universes and a ton of them but now they
described uh they described it as
parallel Dimensions rather than
universes within universes so it's now a
parallel time
um so it's like it's just going parallel
There's No Going deeper so Marvel Comics
has said you're saying Marvel Comics has
said the microverse is like the the
bottom
no you can't go any any deeper no you
could you could that was the microverse
you could make universities
getting smaller gotcha you could have
been in the micro first there was a
bunch of planets and stuff it was like
because we kind of right now we
envisioned the quantum realm as we've
seen very little of it it's like Doom
have his own planet in the micro version
no I didn't mean to cut you off I'm like
very good oh great
um really quick though what we know from
the quantum realm now because since it's
kind of not the microverse is still very
little it is unknown a lot about it
because no one really dives into it but
we know that it is uh they use it we
know time and space doesn't matter it's
used to jump alternate timelines and
time travel and who better at that than
Kang himself right so could Kane create
his own Quantum realm within the quantum
realm could that be what he's actually
going for it's like his intention is not
necessarily get out but to make another
realm side of it so I what I when I was
going to the chronopolis part that Tommy
was saying that we know in the comics
that he did create there could be
essentially a situation where he's
trying to create chronopolis without
using the chronopolis that we see that
Bill Murray is in charge of because you
we even looked it up that pain read was
like this isn't chronopolis he said it
but he yeah so in Ant-Man 2 when they're
like leaving when Hank goes to get Janet
and they're heading out you see this
little thing on the side off in the
background it looks like a city yeah and
in the comics there was like krannapolis
right which uh that's where a Kang lived
he would steal stuff and put it in
chronopolis or whatever uh and so people
asking Rita was like oh is that
chronopolis he said no but it was a city
it was like supposed to imply that there
were people living down there it wasn't
just Janet walking around with crazy
animals like there was a whole
civilization down there right yes no 100
at least one yeah so it could there's a
I would love this to be another quantum
realm another inside another quantum
room just because I want a bigger bigger
Universe inside of a tiny universe
universe but essentially if everything
is horizontal that could just be a
um Scott going through
and coming out at a different time
because they're just using it to
alternate or jump alternate timelines
like oh he's whatever that yellow thing
he's going into yeah it's a portal to
take him to different lines or something
because if it is just all kind of linear
or at least maybe sometimes important
because remember he's like that's what
Kank says I can give you what you can
give you want the most time so he just
keeps pushing him through this little
circle of tentacles and he keeps coming
back out at this point okay but when you
do create another timeline remember
you're creating it entirely if this is
the timeline and then you bounce off
yeah you make another new one so I don't
know if it's a monkey paw situation
where it's like you can jump in and come
out and then you're gonna be
you could be pruned
oh oh God if the TVA program that'd be
kind of messed up
um what do you guys think about I guess
it's kind of like a theory but do you
think that that could be the situation
that he's going through a dimension or a
Quantum Realm
yeah I mean the physics of it or how
you're explaining it I guess it makes
sense that it's more of a like rather
than going to a different like
completely different space it's like
it's like a wormhole almost right like
it's like he's going things are like the
reality is expanding and Contracting so
are you drawing an infinity symbol yes
okay uh well that could be possible
right because we talked about on the
show already the idea that if you know
science has showed us if one thing
exists there's probably more right you
know at one point we thought uh uh the
solar system was the only one in the
whole universe but now we know there's
tons of them we thought Earth was the
only planet where a humans could live
but now there's tons of them we thought
there was only one universe but now
there's the idea in our world of like
bubble universes and multiverses in our
world right so it makes sense that if
you can go down and you keep going down
there's probably not a floor you
probably keep going down now one thing
this makes me think of Jessica when you
describe this to me is when they were
talking about time travel and end game
right there was the Einstein Rosen
Bridge or whatever that uh Tony Stark
looks like looked at which kind of
looked like an infinity symbol and he
was like this is little thoughts but
that if that's true right if you you're
in the quantum realm let's say you're
down in the quantum realm and you want
to get out maybe you go down
to get out and you come back out on top
and eventually if you kept going down
you would Loop all the way around and
get back to where you were before the
idea that it's like it's not a straight
line down all the way down right at some
point it Loops back around oh yeah so we
talked about like if King really wants
to get out maybe the way to get out is
not going up yeah it's going down maybe
because he keeps trying to go up he
keeps ending up down yeah lost in the
woods he's into the woods
um when you keep going down I guess when
do you hit a plane that is because
remember when um Ant-Man got himself I
think this was in the second one I think
it was in the second Airman he gets so
small and they go to like a subatomic
they say subatomic but like you've got
something the bottom floor what what's
stopping him uh Kang from just reaching
the bottom floor then I don't think
there is no bottom you don't think there
is no bottom what was that place that he
was in that he was just floating I think
he could have kept going he was able to
stop his regulator at that point and he
was like I gotta get back to Cassie you
see he was just kind of like in
Blackness right we saw that which was it
what was later shown as like the quantum
realm maybe he went past it at some
point went too far uh but he just
stopped he probably could have kept
going but yeah I gotta go up I gotta
switch the little thing and it started
going back up okay he's the only one
that could has ever done it on his own
there's also so if it isn't a Quantum
realm because the quantum room would
make it massive and you would have to
the science so that would be deep it
could
also be a dimension in what's saying
because in the micro verse we know that
there was a lot of different planets and
a lot of different there's Homeworld
there was all these places so I assume
that in the quantum realm there's
different cities okay there's
differences do you think this is just a
different part of the quantum realm that
he's getting shot through I mean that's
possible because if you have this like
Quantum realm and you have Kang and he's
the ruling and you also have like Bill
Murray's crew and their like high
society and you also have like these
Freedom Fighters there's got to be
enough space yeah that all these people
can hide from each other and like not be
on top of vision so it's got to be
massive yeah and in the end
you must protect your neck oh okay
thanks for the kids you're really good
at that one that's a good simple well
it's a bit of a passion of mine do you
think the Wu-Tang Clan will show up in
the quantum room uh definitely you God
uh probably not inspected deck Raekwon
maybe maybe Dewey ODB that's where he's
been hiding do we think if they go
deeper into the quantum realm that they
will eventually find Wanda
oh you think she could be there yeah
so I'm just like I feel like Wanda could
show up in the quantum room and she
could have been in there this entire
time and that is
the Silver Surfer did in the comics and
the microverse to hide away from
Galactus or the hide away from the
Fantastic Four because they needed his
help he ran into the quantum realm and
hid in the city she's hiding the hell
what if she's hiding in there with Bill
Murray and she's on the rich part but
that is also an adjacent story I still
don't think we'll see her before
Covenant chaos yeah she shows up in
company I do too I'm with you on that
I'm bullish on that thing bullish
bullish bullish on that theory so we
think okay personally I guess I think
that it's not going through a realm to
another realm but what do we feel about
if Bill Murray this entire time has the
creation to create another realm or
Dimension and that's what Kang is trying
to get to oh Bill Murray's like made a
secret little spine yeah I wouldn't be I
think even though it seems impossible to
create a quantum realm in the quantum
realm Kang would have the possibility to
do it he's the only person that can
control time and space and everything
and we're not the only one but he can do
it and he's in the quantum realm so it's
like what's stopping him from trying to
create something within something and I
think the one thing that's stopping him
is Bill Murray so what if Bill Murray's
already working on something like this
oh secretly working against him because
it seems like Bill Murray's gonna be
aligned with Kang right you think that's
not like a good way well not a good way
no I think in a way that like oh I want
to be rich and I live a life of luxury
here in the I think he's going to be
like the guy in Die Hard that tries to
negotiate with Hans Gruber like he's a
bad guy but he's like a more impotent
type of bad guy
gang Bubby let's talk
you want some stingrays to ride around
on get your stingrays that's insane you
see an avatar I got Avatar down here on
LaserDisc
uit they have laser disc in the quantum
room they have bars I don't think they
have anything's possible if they have
bars it stands to reason they have
brothels billiard Halls casinos take me
to a a Quantum realm casino and let me
play little baby Blackjack Jesus Christ
all right
um look that's that's all I have with
this discussion I don't yeah ultimately
I don't think it's a Quantum room inside
a Quantum realm but it is probably
another dimension what do you think do
you think he's making a dimension down
there I don't think he's making a
dimension I genuinely think that those
tentacles can you show me the tentacles
again John show me the temperature I
think he's going through a dimension um
and or he's using the quantum Mel to
jump time ah okay and I think this is a
part of uh Kings plan do you think this
is like a hyper like this is like a
built-in hyperdrive like he can speed
Through Time faster once he goes that
because it kind of does seem like he's
accelerating right I know he is falling
down so that that's gravity as well but
I'm wondering if maybe that's like a uh
not a mirror to the the the the way the
um
telecondell had that like water stream
that made them get be able to get down
to telecon faster I wonder if that's
like the I don't know it's a light up
arrow and Mario Karts yeah yes exactly
that's accelerate your speed yeah or
it's the little uh the things in f-zero
they do the same thing yeah start for
mandatory fun
after the f-zero drop that's right once
I mention f-zero you know it's time to
play that graphic hero hit it again
foreign
Jessica's birthday so you know we got to
play that graphic tray hit it again
Trace three
I've been better
I've been worse play that graphic like
it's a curse hit it again
you want the Thirsty that's me no I do
not I would like a new graphic all right
we don't have to play The Thirsty
thespian graph right move on just hit us
again with that tentacle pit
I don't want it
oh there we go beautiful so tiny
so tiny so small canceled all right now
first of all a deep heartfelt thanks to
all of you trash dumpster people that
watch my mode oh buttock video I wrote a
trailer once again when I write my own
dialogue I write like a child
misspellings incorrect errors anyway I
like uh many of you I'm thrilled that
Modoc is finally in the MCU but
he's not the only large Cranium member
right of popular culture sure villainous
large-headed beings there's me there's
Mt Megamind Megamind I forgot to include
him in this segment but I appreciate you
bringing up so guys I uh took took the
liberty to make a little bit of a of a
group I've made a gang a click if you
will I call them the Society of big
skulls or sobs okay
you describe it okay so these are
popular big-headed villains yeah I'm not
helping from movies and right now I am
in no particular order there are no
particular order
but uh what I want to do for mandatory
fund is I want us to rank rank these men
who have to buy hats online they can't
buy off the rack because they got such
big heads now we already know Modoc
we're all excited about Modoc the views
don't lie guys I'm going virus
virus you're gonna rank him high modak
is number okay for your big heads but
I've got five other nominees we've got
Krang not Kang crang from Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles we've got Mr Electric
George Lopez himself Sharkboy and
Lavagirl this is from the Spy Kids
Universe yeah Sharkboy and Lava we've
got Brandon Frazier and the whale no I'm
kidding it's Hector Hammond he's wearing
Prosthetics he's that's fat Erasure okay
okay
Stolen Valor John stolen calorie uh
Hector Hector Hammond from Green Lantern
then we have the leader who will be
returning and then we have Sinestro who
by the way this big head eraser because
current iterations of Sinestro they've
shrunk in his head that's pretty big
there he's got a big head there uh you
know honorable mentions to Brainiac who
has like a large but proportionately
regular head okay also The Thinker in DC
he's got those bulbs that make his head
look bigger I wanted to throw Pinhead
from Hellraiser in there because it's an
interesting head but it's not really a
yeah that's an optical illusion uh Bruce
Bochy the manager for the Padres and
Giants uh previously wore a size eight
and three quarters hat is that huh is
that big well they only sell up to seven
and three quarters or eight in the store
at the stadiums where they have
everything that the team sells so guys
I'm gonna put them in my order okay and
then I want you guys
you gotta rank from like left to right
yeah because from left to right I'm
gonna go power
and I'm gonna explain quick explainers
on uh
Society why everybody
uh why everybody is ranked where they
are okay so
Hector's heavy he's got a big head yeah
well he has to carry the film yeah
Reynolds Oh my gosh oh my gosh this
magnet's not strong enough all right so
first I have the most powerful member of
the big head gang outside of Modoc and
myself is Sinestro I mean he's part of
the lantern cord before he breaks back
grabs the yellow ring becomes a Yellow
Lantern then I've got crang crank would
be first because he is very powerful he
he controls you know all the foot
soldiers he even has Shredder working
for him doing his spinning however he
gets trapped in dimension X and anyone
that's dumb enough to get trapped like a
Kang
uh or a crane does not get to rank high
up with me next I have the leader leader
is charismatic the leader is a leader of
men the leader is important the leader
will be returning I just feel like
there's a lot of hype wrong
if I were Jim Cramer in that mad money
show I'd hit things like you'd be I'm
buying leader bullish on leader Hector
Hammond turned when he was not looking
like this poor Peter Skarsgard when he
was just hitting on Blake Lively he was
more intimidating and scary then he gets
this like weird uh head thing happening
to him and he's basically just spitting
green news for the rest of the movie
he's not great I don't like him don't
respect him Mr Electric is clearly a
ripoff of Modoc and he's defeated by two
children so
that's my rankings and Hector Hammond
was this his name before the hedge or
does he not take up a new name
this is how lame Hector Hammond is he's
like they're like well what what's your
name and he's like Hector Hammond damn
it I should have thought of something
better
ham head would be better Hector ham
hocks his god-given name that's his
Christian name that's what's on his
license that's when you go to the phone
book it's Hammond comma Hector okay I
love your placement of Sinestro and this
is a great representation of Sinestro
because it has the ring on the left hand
yes which is very Sinister and he's
using it to fire an arrow out of his
genitals yeah which I like which makes
me feel safe it is true I would bump up
the leader yeah above of crank okay no
offense to crank is Crane's head even
that big I mean I mean he's all had
human-sized brain he's all head I guess
I guess you could say that he's in the
belly of the Beast I'll head no breaks I
like that
yeah I have no respect for Hector
Hammond and I think you've been watching
Green Lantern I thought this would
become sin asteroid yeah I he really I
mean I love Peter Skarsgard I like all
three of the main characters in that
movie and I like taika waititi but I
don't like that movie and I think I
think this Mr Electric framing it is
appropriate now Jessica you love
villains
I do love my most attractive and you're
the only person that was age-appropriate
for Sharkboy and Lava Girl Brandon was
only three yeah I was 30. I didn't watch
it but sorry
spot kids almost that's Robert Rodriguez
too yeah yeah no I love Spy Kids so much
so that I refused watching Sharkboy and
Lava Girl was the movie that he was like
my kids told me the story and then
because I'm excited and to be fair I did
watch Sharkboy and Lavagirl once when I
was very very young so I don't really
remember it but I remember the song yeah
look at the story starting to change huh
I don't I remember just the dream song
um and then I I'm very embarrassed do
you remember how it went dream dream
dream oh God I don't want to keep going
no I don't want to see him that's how he
sings That's how Taylor water sings it
um wait you're telling me Taylor Lautner
phoned in I saw a musical number Taylor
Lautner's Sharkboy I know you're saying
you didn't give it his all no
um I would put the leader as number one
I think later not only in the MCU but
mcwish uh and the comics is very
violently good actually no I put on this
too because Sinestro is amazing
F the leader up yeah I was like Sinestro
is number one I think Modoc and the
leader are actually tied
[Music]
um I don't really watch Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles but I believe what you
guys had to say about crying
um
Hector Hammond though
uh I'll leave it I'll leave it you like
it you like these rankings I kind of do
I kind of want to switch these two oh
okay but it's also just because I don't
know this one as well
but I'll allow it we'll allow it I mean
Hector Hammond outside of the movie in
the comics is a little more interesting
he's kind of an older guy this is Frank
eraser dude here's what I think well
he's still above Mr Electric it's true
tell us in the chat if we're missing
anybody and tell us in the chat your
rankings and uh yeah you're you're big
head Heroes I'll go through and ignore
all of those and only focus on the chat
questions to comment on my body uh
because that's what I do we'll update us
decided big skulls
he's like all-time QV he's the king
modak's the big head he's the Josh Allen
of the big head gang yeah I like he's a
Josh Allen with a big head he's the top
of the other thing Chris Kelly and then
sending that Super Chat asking can I
join the big head gang all you're doing
is showing how you don't know anything
about the game look here Tommy Chris
Kelly wants to know how to join the big
head Game Chris Kelly give me your
measurements send another Super Chat in
just kidding
you know what big big heads not just uh
not just the size it's a state of mind
uh so if you want to be in the big head
gang we're all inclusive it's true
anyone could do it you can always
increase the size of your cranium we did
get some other super chats about uh uh
Ant-Man and was quantumania uh uh one of
the questions was I think it was from
GSU Eagle also known as Ebenezer splooge
how does everyone get their suits in the
quantum realm they weren't wearing them
when being pulled in so they just have
shrunken versions in their pocket no I
mean you know there's a tailor if
there's a bartender if there's a
governor
I think yeah I think there's someone
that's making that wear I think treating
this world and I talk about this on
inside Marvel kind of like Star Wars
world is like yeah a people people
barter people are creating things and
people are making profit off of it well
we do know we do know that they love to
keep tiny suits in their pocket that
happens all the time also
the nanotechnology has been introduced
in the MCU you think it's already anyone
else at any moment
it's just like living in their ears oh
you're talking about
you're talking about the team like
you're talking about the pins yeah I'm
talking about the people in the room I
was like there's a person there that too
is their clothes
that's so funny no yes I think their
suits are made to shrink and grow I
think it's made to do both because we
know that wasps can uh stature is now
getting hers probably inside yeah or not
if you've had one she might get hers
from the quantum yeah exactly and then
we know Hank or not Hank I mean hers
looks very kang-esque I wonder if she
teams up with old King and also she's
like screw you Dad Jana has different
clothes than when in the beginning of
the trailer well there she gets her
we're gonna do this trailer again I had
a big argument with John about this
there's a part in this new trailer where
stature's like looking in front of this
portal and it looks like they're back in
the workshop do you think they got out I
think there's a lot of in and out he's
uh uh both for Life saying Scott is
King's downfall I think well he doesn't
have to win they just both have to lose
I don't know I don't know
yeah uh and if I could just quickly
interject okay
this is Santa Claus he's crying two
tears and he's saying Mrs Claus is
having an affair oh my God so do what
you will with that today thank goodness
you're uh I think that's your go-to is
drawing the Santa Claus yeah and the
Wu-Tang Clan symbol uh the new one
suggested speaking of Wu-Tang Clan that
uh because you we invoke the name of the
clan themselves Kang's theme song should
be conqueror Kang ain't nothing to F oh
yeah the killer killer king maybe maybe
he has a little karaoke down there
karaoke trash bag saying they saw fan
art of Ant-Man attention goes way before
this trailer came out oh do not search
for fan art yeah or your favorite
character with tentacles please don't uh
real tree pointing out Scott's gonna do
real small things this year damn sure
xenix saying do we think you can see a
special presentation of Kang this year
which could better explain him for
audiences who may not be familiar with
the comics I could see us doing a
special presentation on a certain King
like a difference
because there is a king that is like
that's a great point we don't know if
that's this king from the quantum realm
we don't know if it's a different King
okay that's right in the TVA we don't
know that one do we call that one
conqueror King who's gonna be conqueror
King also uh
they did they did kind of dropped the
word conquer a little bit I think you
know a friend of the show koi John Dro
has frequently brought up using the
special presentations as introductions
for other characters I do think there is
a little fire to that smoke you know I
think that that that's a great I it
doesn't seem like there's I mean
werewolf by night was so well received
I'd be surprised if that's the last we
get of that character but but it doesn't
seem like there's immediate plans for
what's his name Jack Russell his name is
Jack Russell which is adorable way to go
comic book writers but I could see the
Bloodstone and all of that coming in to
play uh very soon but I yeah I'm
interested to see a king special
presentation would be awesome but I I
wonder we've had so much of him already
that that may not yeah I don't know I
mean he's the big MacGuffin for most
movies we assume but we'll have to see
and we hope to get more special
presentations this year
um but where the dreads because you
brought up Wanda Jessica I want to talk
about this one setting a Super Chat
saying if you think uh if you think
about there's still one dark hole left
right we know all the dark holes have
been destroyed book of Ashanti's gone
they pointed out that strange has a
photographic memory in the first movie
so he could potentially still remember
the book and there's one more chip also
like that Temple like collapsed yeah but
it wasn't like it's exploded who wrote
it again it was it wasn't uh yeah I was
like how I say no I forgot if I want to
say Cthulhu um Cthulhu
um I would love the day for that demon
to come out break out I pitched him
breaking out in Blade and being able to
rewrite that book again
I'm gonna have to kill so many people to
build that Temple again John's coming in
hot I'm kathon I have strong feelings oh
boy
Doctor Strange destroyed the dark hold
in every Dimension that's he did not
destroy the temple in every dimension
find Wonder guard again I mean you
assume that there's a temple in every
every timeline I'm sure there's at least
one there's a there's
one more I bet Kangaskhan he's got a
temple down in chronopolis well that was
what
was what our theories at darkhold shrunk
down in the uh in the quantum realm oh
tiny dark cold in the quantum realm
we'll never know we'll never know until
February 17th when it will all be
revealed thanks for tuning in to the
break room today folks if you haven't
already be sure to hit the like button
subscribe to the channel if you didn't
do that uh Mike and cheers getting a
last-minute Super Chat I want Captain
America to come in and save Ant-Man from
getting gang stopped because they're
best buds yeah oh
hit that like button subscribe to the
channel join us here every weekday we'll
be talking about all the fun stuff you
like to talk about it we'll be back
tomorrow at the same time so be sure to
tune in uh like And subscribe like I
said Tommy's got that Modoc video out on
the channel you haven't seen it already
he's liking keep watching keep liking
And subscribe gosh dang it if you
haven't subscribed yet you're missing
out on all the fun you never know when
we'll go live inside Marvel's going to
be out on the channel tomorrow uh
Jessica and Mt is are heading up that
they've got some great discussion on
there uh and uh the Ant-Man trailer
breakdown that MC just did is out on the
channel now don't miss it yeah check it
out please do check it out uh and be
sure to watch last of us this weekend
because we're all excited about that
show yeah and we'll be talking about it
here on the break room as well uh thanks
for tuning in today thanks for all your
super chants thanks for being you we
hope you have a great rest of your day
enjoy your evening we'll see you here
tomorrow latest games
[Music]
it's true
[Music]